yeah welcome to this video playing the
Dragon King and I won't allow the dragon
better not maybe against the Dragon King
the most boring opening known to man
that's right the right recipe I played
90 for now this is some way to get an a
symmetrical position at least I think
something like this is so as soon as the
theoretical line I had this before I
think in some some blitz game okay
there should be seven wins the exchange
and he's not really doing something
against this fish would be 75 bishop eh
takes a form looks it looks bit tricky
indeed I don't let's let's not do that
better keep control of this position
attending irukum rook b7 was my original
intention but his plate will be eight
maybe queen d 626 quickly played if i
take is taking with the porn him okay
yeah maybe just just drop back what is
it trapped really you got food this is a
slightly embarrassing yeah didn't think
about that at all is it really trapped
yeah it is what can I do wait
yeah yeah you can see here even I could
have taken be one and turn and win the
Queen I simply forgot about who gave
head I mean completely you know yeah I
need to play some normal let's say yeah
and then it's somewhere between equal
intend and slide something yeah maybe
they's slide something even this is a
bit weak hey I completely overlooked
Bishop f8 ah yeah thanks for watching